hey everybody and welcome to live coding
with Jesse sorry I started a few minutes
later than scheduled
I forgot to open up OBS which is my
streaming software and so I went to
start the stream and realized I didn't
even have it open so I had to open it
and put in the youtube code and at the
same time I was having a debate on slack
about Star Wars with a co-worker so if
anybody's a Star Wars fan you know how
important that is so anyway I have we
had a lot of news today so we've had a
lot of pull requests I've set up what I
think will be a helpful way to track our
progress on this project and plan things
out and then also I had a meeting this
morning kind of a long meeting but the
result was was pretty cool so I'm gonna
share that with you because it's gonna
be a big deal when it in terms of what
we're gonna be working on on this dream
you know really for the next year or
more in developing so I don't think
we'll be working on it every day for the
next year or more but we're gonna it's
going to be probably the most important
project for at least the next year so
let me let me get to it so I guess I'll
just share with the project is first I
don't want to keep you all in suspense
and I'm pretty excited about it so I
don't know exactly when we're gonna
start on this but if you remember in
projects was it - maybe project 3 so we
were working on the main website so let
me hear that and
so you all remember that we were working
well those of you who watch the stream
out a few weeks or so ago we were
working on this probably remember there
we go
I'll bring this up so you remember one
how slow the main website is that took
forever all right
and how outdated it is really cluttered
a lot of stuff going on here so this is
the main website for the university that
workout it gets by far more traffic than
all our other websites combined so it's
it's the most important site this is
where most people see the online
presence of University at this site and
probably never see any of our other
sites this is part of the the redesign
that we are working on together they
didn't get very far with it but
definitely an improvement you know just
in terms of the things we have they're
already a big improvement for some
reason that's interesting the side nav
hasn't been working unless you hard
refresh the page anyway not really the
point so here's the point one of the
issues that we had in making a little
bit difficult to develop this site is
that the backend for it is a content
management system called Ektron that's
based on asp.net and we don't have
direct control or direct access to the
database and I'm not that familiar with
dotnet things so basically what I what's
I'm pretty sure this is gonna happen I
don't want to say a hundred percent sure
because we've been talking about it for
a long time so I'm still a little bit
careful as to whether or not this is
gonna happen but I think it will we're
gonna do away with the Eckstrom system
we're gonna rebuild it completely from
the ground up back and front end
database everything and as we've
discussed in previous streams the
is to tie this into probably a wordpress
for the content manager WordPress
back-end for content management system
we're going to use graph QL to grab the
data from wordpress like we're doing
with this current project project 4 and
then we're going to have multiple
multiple droplets chris will probably be
on this relation so multiple droplets
running node that are low balanced to
handle all the traffic and then the
front end of it is going to be built
with react and so it'll be very similar
to what we're doing here for this site
but on a much larger scale because the
main website has i think it's over 3000
pages the biggest challenges we're going
to have though are getting all the
content out of the current database and
into a wordpress database in the format
that it needs to be in for wordpress or
if we decide to go with some other
system you know we could do it but
basically we need to get the data out
we've talked about this before on the
stream and i think we decided that the
best way to go about this would be to
make some sort of an api to get that
data out so that needs to happen and
whether that be we do that on the stream
or try to figure it out or have to hire
someone else to work on that because
that's databases aren't really my my
strong suit so obviously we have a long
time to work on it so it's possible that
i can learn enough to make that happen
we'll see how it goes
otherwise everything else is are things
that we've already worked on another
project so this will be just kind of
combining everything on a much larger
scale and doing a lot of testing there's
gonna be a lot of different you know
there's gonna be a lot of users so the I
guess there's more pressure on this
project more people were gonna see it
it's going to be more obvious I guess if
we mess something up so I guess there's
pressure on me you all there's no
pressure on you because it's all my
responsibility but I'm excited I'm
really excited
like I said not sure when we're gonna
start it but in terms of design you know
we've already have some of the design
finished I mean this this header is is
nice I mean probably the link structure
is going to change that's not really up
to me I'll be in the meetings about that
but it's not going to be entirely up to
me what links are there but hey I just
checked the live chat and my uncle is in
the live chat hey Uncle fat also glad
you could that you could watch okay so
enough about that project
you're definitely hearing more about it
and in the upcoming weeks and so I'm
excited so today we're gonna do two
things the first thing I'm going to do
is I'm going to show you how I've set up
using a Kanban board and using github
projects a layout so that we can all
track this project together so that you
know what still needs to be done and
they're all going to be linked up to
github issues so that it's easy for us
to discuss them and to track them
because until now you all just been kind
of going by what we discussed in the
live streams so I think this will be
much more clear you know what we still
have left to do it'll be nice to track
everything and I think it's night I use
this kind of thing for all my projects
it it helps me organize everything so I
know I've shown you a little bit of how
I do this on Trello but I'm gonna try to
do this within github and then that way
there's not so many different places to
go to keep track of the same project the
second thing we're going to do is go
over some pull requests because we've
gotten a lot of pull requests over the
last weekend and I didn't it was a long
weekend for me so I wasn't in Monday or
Tuesday so I didn't stream so I'm gonna
save that for the second part of it so
let me start my timer I'm gonna start
this 25-minute Pomodoro timer and then
that will reminding me that after 25
minutes I need to take a break and
answer some questions in the live chat
this probably will end up being a
shorter stream than normal because we're
not going to do a lot of
actual coding this is going to be more
of like project planning and review code
review so we'll see how much time it
takes but I'm thinking maybe around an
hour for the stream length so let me
show you let me bring this over on this
screen so you can see I'll bring this up
you can see let's see I see there are
some questions in the lab chat I will
get to those on my first break so don't
think I'm am ignoring them okay so
here's what we have now on the project
I'm gonna make this a bit bigger so you
can see so this is our bulletin reactive
current project that we were working on
and I just went to the repository and
then I clicked on this projects tab I
just made you know one project called
bulletin you can add a description of
these if you want but this is the only
one so I mean they make it a bit smaller
just you can see kind of the big picture
here so for a Kanban board
this is the kind of an old way of a
visual way to look at a project flow you
don't even need to do this online you
can do it with sticky notes on a wall or
something basically all you need is
three columns so you need you know your
to-do column you're in progress and then
your your done column I like to expand
it out a little bit when I first learned
how to do this this was the setup that I
learned with and for me I like this
because I usually try to put in there
ready for development column everything
that I think I can complete in one week
and then it's nice to have a testing
column not everything goes in there the
testing column sometimes things are
really minor changes that are so
straightforward that you test as soon as
you do it you see that it works doesn't
really require a lot of testing and
those usually can go right to the
completed because you kind of do the
testing step right there and then I also
like to add this wish list and these are
things that would be really awesome to
add to a project but it's probably not
going to happen
for launch and not a project requirement
so these are if you want to challenge
these are probably where the most
challenging things would be but probably
the coolest things to work on as well so
I've added some things I've added some
things and you can see from setting this
up earlier today just a few hours ago
we've already had something moved from
the to-do list to the completed list and
so these when I when I add these in I
just add them as a note and then you can
click the drop down and you know it
doesn't show it now because I already
did it you can click the drop down and
convert it to an issue and then it
automatically goes into the issues then
you can put more information and if you
want code snippets or images you know
whatever you want and there can be
discussions so several of these issues
have discussions back and forth with
those of you who are you know
contributing to the project so it's it's
nice but I have done this with Trello
before but it is really nice to be able
to have it all in one place so I'm gonna
try to make this work the only thing
that I don't have with this that I had
with Trello that I really liked was
being able to track how long each one of
these took using Pomodoro sessions so I
was checking out some Chrome extensions
that could maybe do that but I haven't
found one that works exactly you know
how it did with Trello so I'm thinking
about I'm gonna keep looking for one if
you know of anything like that then let
me know otherwise I may attempt to
create one myself I don't know when I'll
have time to do that but it it would be
cool to have something where you could
attach time estimates to each one of
these that would be that would be nice
and then if it could also produce some
sort of burn down chart automatically
that would be that useful as well
me that's actually pretty
straightforward if anybody has questions
about this put in a live chat I'm gonna
keep looking over so that I can answer
questions
you see kinda think I'm missing
something this seems to - easy - to
explain
I actually I think I think that's it con
bonds really straightforward and it's
simple which is why I like it so much
you know you just you move the cards
over okay cool so so Pat says JIRA does
both estimates and multiple reports I
was I was actually checking out JIRA
before the stream started does anybody
else use JIRA you know of that so JIRA
seemed like it had the most features out
of anything else I checked out in terms
of tracking this and doing there's a lot
of charts and reports there's so many
cool things that could do so I might
have to check into that more I didn't
really have time to check into it before
the stream as much as I think I needed
to to do a stream on it but I'm assuming
that there's also integrations with
github I know there is you can link up
Trello with github issues so I'm
assuming you could do the same thing
with JIRA or maybe use something like
like zapier to link it up but that that
seems like it would be pretty pretty
powerful let's see okay world says this
is more for agile type workflows yes
so I've the Connie the context of agile
was where I actually learned this I was
taking a course on agile for for one so
I was not working on a team it was more
me working by myself but I wanted to
incorporate as much of you
agile project management as I could so
that's where I learned this so anyway I
think this will help so I may or may not
stick with doing this and get up if I
can find if I find that it doesn't have
everything that I need or there's
something better out there that I could
work with that's great the only thing I
would want is for you all to be able to
have access to this to at least see it
you don't necessarily need to be able to
edit it I mean I could certainly take
care of moving these cards over every
time one of these issues is either you
know it's solved
so if we can find something like that
I'm certainly open to it otherwise I'll
maybe try to find a plug in all right so
let me let me quickly go over one other
thing with the Trello board before we
actually get into some code so you'll
notice I have some labels here if you're
already familiar with how github issues
work I'm sure you know what's going on
with these labels but if you're not then
I'm gonna try to label the issues as
accurately as possible but the important
labels for people who I guess are new is
this good first issued label so if you
don't have a lot of pull requests or
you're looking for your first pull
request for your github profile check
these out I'm gonna try to put this tag
on everything that is that I think will
be easy for beginners so sometimes it
may be something as simple as adding a
little bit of documentation even
potentially correcting a typo so I'm
gonna make sure I do this I'm gonna
purposely not complete some of the
easier tasks and make them issues and
then that way you know it can help you
get that that first pull request I know
it can be intimidating sometimes a lot
of projects are really complex and not
quite so easy to get into
so this would be good for for some of
the newer people and then also I'm gonna
have some more some more complicated
issues this I would say is a bit more
complicated and let's see so I want to
actually take a look at this especially
if you're not familiar with without
github works and we're just going to
take a look at one of these issues the
only other label I want to point out is
this hack hack Tober fest issue if you
search for hack Tober fest this is
basically an opportunity for you to get
a free t-shirt so if you sign up for
this and link your github account and
you you have four pool requests that get
merged in the open source projects then
you'll get a free t-shirt so check that
out and I think it's all the way through
October I forget what the end date is
but it's kind of a cool a cool thing so
that's why I added this label here just
to let everybody know that this is you
know this is open for issues let's see
pad has a question says do you keep a
backlog of items to complete right now I
don't have a backlog well I should at
least for this project I haven't set up
anything I didn't I didn't even start to
do anything on this project till a while
an hour or two ago so I don't have
anything yet for my some of the other
projects that I had a more developed
board for I did have quite a large
backlog for some of them yeah I guess
the to do you to do it works kind of
like a backlog and the way I have this
set up so I don't have a separate
backlog so I saw with with JIRA there is
a way to do have a separate backlog so
basically this ends up
the backlog my projects because it's
usually just me working on them they're
not really large-scale so it doesn't
usually get too big it's pretty easy to
handle but if you had a much larger
project you might even want multiple
multiple boards so I would I would say
this setup does work well for me if it's
for a small project a really small team
but larger ones would probably need
something more and actually so uncle Pat
if we get a chance to talk I would
really love to see how how you handle
because I know you work on some some
much larger projects I'd love to see how
you handle the workflow because you know
I just I'm just trying to figure this
out on my own I've never had like a team
or you know someone else to work with
and learn from and how to do this so
let's see if you all don't know I am so
my uncle was here in the live stream and
he is a software developer and has been
for for a long time and I'm not gonna
give like details about company or
anything because I'm not sure if you
want me to or not but works with I
believe c-sharp and yeah so definitely
has been a great help and to me and kind
of my path to becoming a developer and
so anyway I'm really excited that he's
he's watching so oh okay I said I was
gonna click this and then I get
sidetracked all right so here's the
issue right so if you go to look at a
github repository you can check out you
can get straight to the issues or if
you're in the project view you can click
on the issue and so
this is basically what it isn't you can
submit issues as well so it doesn't have
to be me as the manager of this
repository you can submit issues as you
see them and you can even put in you
know screenshots links whatever you need
to so in this particular case I guess
there's no discussion for this one I'll
click another one where you add
discussion but in this particular case
you could ask questions you know we
could go back and forth on you know what
we think we could assign this to someone
like I said since we don't really have
it's just me working on it I usually
don't assign but you can see how useful
it is in being able to have a place to
discuss each issue and then when you
submit a pull request to complete this
issue the issue then would get closed
and we have a record of all the issues
so in particular for this one let's see
so one of the things that was done in a
pull request over the weekend
Harshit submitted a bunch of pull
requests is that he got that grid
working in terms of switching back and
forth between the list layout and the
grid layout but the way it's working
there's a gap between our cards so in
for this issue we just want to get rid
of that gap so I have offered some
suggestions to repurpose some code from
a previous project and I've linked to
that that code here I think that will
solve the problem but it'll take some
adjustment of the way the code is set up
currently let's see let me just to show
you an example let me show you this once
we so we can have discussion back and
forth and talk about it so anyway for
those of you that are used to get hub I
know this is pretty basic but I I do
know there's a lot of you that watch
that may not have a gate
profile yet or you just started out so
it can be somewhat confusing if you're
not used to it okay I see a dual ask is
there any chance you could share the
link about this agile course yeah if I
remember I can find the link if you want
to try to look for it it's I think it's
called agile for one and it's on
Pluralsight so Pluralsight is has a lot
of online courses there are a couple of
different ways to get a free trial of
fluoro sites you can test it out without
having to pay for it but normally you
have to pay for it so I think the
Microsoft developer programmers there's
some sort of Microsoft developer program
that you can sign up for it it's free
and it comes with I think a three month
free trial to Pluralsight that's what I
did and I just try to do as many classes
as I could before my trial ran out so
check that out if you want to otherwise
after I'm done with the stream maybe
I'll try to find the link and I'll put
it in the video or the fire remember
I'll put it in the live chat tomorrow
okay one more thing I want to tell you
about that change before we get to some
more the code is if you're using this
project now if you want to download this
and run it on your own machine you need
to be running node so nodejs
version 7.6 or higher so we're using
some newer JavaScript syntax and it's
not supported in older versions so if
you're getting an error about the async
okay good eric says it's microsoft dev
essentials so that's that's what it is
check out the microsoft dev essentials
there's other cool stuff you get for
free with that as well so definitely
check it out so let me show you what I'm
talking about we have the so we now have
a try to find a server folder and within
the server folder we have app dot J s
and this is harsh it did all the work
for this
but one of the things it does is it uses
on this line line 11 it does use async
so you'll get in you'll see that there's
an error on line 11 if you don't have
the the correct node version so that
kind of got me at first when I try to
run this it took me a little while to
figure out what the problem was luckily
I had remembered reading about newer
node versions supporting this and then I
finally realized what the problem was
but other than that everything should
work just make sure when you download
the latest version of the repository if
you already had it on your machine that
you run npm install or yarn to get all
the newest dependencies so let me go
through it's probably going to it would
take a while to go through everything on
the pool request that happened so I'm
just going to quickly go over each one
and of course you can check out you know
line by line what happened with each one
in the repository so let's look at our
close pull requests and let me go from
[Music]
ok so from 11 on these are things that
are new so in this one our should added
that grid layout that I just showed you
all recently there are also some other
minor changes that I'm kind of skipping
over so but this was a significant
amount of code it took me quite a while
to go through everything and test it all
before I merged it in an error handler
so basically what happens now is when
you go let's see if we can find it here
so if there's no network connection
you'll get an error instead of the the
loading spinner just continually running
forever you will actually get an error
that says there's something wrong with
the network and you can test it out I'll
do it here briefly you can test it out
by turning off
the network so let me switch to offline
and let's click I have to do this in the
right order so let's get with your first
all right now let's try to go offline
and see if it'll let us do this there we
go
so it says Network error failed to fetch
so they did already have this saved so
that's why I displayed it but otherwise
we'll get that I'll probably change this
I don't really want to show the user you
know the read error message I think
it'll be nicer I want to do something I
want to make it seem like it's not
really that big of a deal just hey check
your internet connection or something
like that
so I'm not sure how I want to word that
or display that but really good idea at
least to give the user some feedback
instead of just the spinning thing
because we'll know immediately whether
or not there's a network connection so
why make the user wait if if we're
already sure that it's not going to look
so that was a great idea thanks for that
our should also and this is to me the
biggest thing the server for the API and
authentication so this is really cool so
we're actually are going to look at this
code for a minute because this is this
significant this kind of goes beyond a
lot of the basic stuff that we had been
working on previous to this so here's
what we're doing we're actually routing
the the data that we're getting from
graph QL and in WordPress and instead of
bringing it straight into our component
it's like client-side right we're gonna
bring it in server-side so you can see I
believe it's at the bottom here I think
where we actually go
here we go so you can see here's that
URL that we were heading client-side
before and now we're getting that data
server side and then where we we would
have gotten things see if I have it up
here I don't think I do
okay let's bring up graph QL Apollo
client so whereas before we were hitting
that wordpress site directly now we're
calling that that back-end that server
and grabbing the data from there and I
think this will be important for us for
for a couple of reasons number one it's
going to help us to protect that that
WordPress installation right because we
want it to be password protected or I
should rather not have passwords I'd
rather have it be a pass with this login
but I'm still working with the IT
department to see how exactly we're
gonna integrate this with our single
sign-on system so now what it allows us
to do is check for whatever kind of
authorization we're gonna have here
server side and only then be able to
load that data also when we do it like
this just kind of thinking of the
possibilities I think this gives us a
nice opportunity for some caching here
like a server-side cache right because
so I like you know client-side caching
right and we already have because we use
create react app to set this up we have
a serviceworker running that's going to
do a lot of caching so in it is a
progressive web app in that sense that
you can turn on and we saw this with a
previous project when I showed you like
on my phone right we could turn off the
network we put it on airplane mode
and clicked around and everything still
worked with the exception of the forms
you know obviously but here we'll still
gonna have that which is awesome but if
we had a cash that was on the server
then it didn't matter who clicked right
so with a client-side that's great but
it only helps out to cut down on
requests for that one person when you
have this server-side cash here anybody
that tries to to go to our site the
request is going to stop here it's not
set up yet but when we set it up the
request will stop here and then press a
request will never get sent back to our
WordPress installation
so that's going to significantly cut
down on the amount of traffic that's
going from our react site to WordPress
so I really like that idea it's gonna
allow us to set up WordPress on a much
smaller server and less powerful server
than we would need to otherwise now this
site granted it doesn't get that much
traffic it's an internal site you know
it'll be less than you know 500 users so
I'm not super worried about it but this
is going to be really important to test
and make sure it works for the next
project that we will be working on for
the main site because that's going to
get a significant amount of traffic so
I'd love to test this out and get it
working here on a small scale so that
maybe it could help later on because
WordPress can sometimes be notorious for
for taking a lot of resources so if we
can cut down on the load that's gonna
come you know back to WordPress then
that's that's going to be a huge help so
those are like the main the main two
reasons why I think this is going to be
really important and really helpful so
if you want to you know kind of go
through this line by line on your own
then you know go right ahead and we'll
be working with this more in streams so
we'll have to go through it and add to
it and modify it a bit but right now
really awesome works well so really
happy about that
thank you harsh it I'm gonna go ahead
and do a short five-minute break I'm
gonna check out the live chat answer any
questions and then we're going to come
back and briefly go over the rest of
these pull requests okay cool so I'm
gonna see actually just saw so Pat says
set up multiple caches one for the
server for generics cool logos pictures
etc then set up a client-side cache for
student admin oriented cache data
actually yeah that's a good idea
I forget to mention this but right now
right now the way we're using WordPress
on our sites where we're pulling from
the WordPress API or graph QL is that
we're still serving all the pictures
from WordPress so obviously that's no
good right because it still sends a lot
of requests back to WordPress but what
I'd like to do is serve those images
elsewhere so I like the idea that users
can upload an image into WordPress right
there when they're making a post that
makes it easy for people who aren't
familiar with code to edit things but
what I would like to happen is that the
images themselves are sent from maybe
some sort of content delivery network so
I have some ideas for how to implement
that I need to test some things out but
I think it can be done and it won't it
shouldn't be too difficult and we should
be able to load the images much more
quickly and completely take the the
strain off of WordPress from having to
serve those to everyone so I think it's
a great idea
let's see okay let me scroll up and see
if there's any questions hey everybody I
see everybody saying hi at the beginning
cool we have good day from Zimbabwe hey
welcome ding ding Ghana says good day
from Zimbabwe
okay cool Todd says awesome I've been
working on one for a past couple weeks
use jQuery at first now I'm trying it
with do you can't wait to compare with
this yeah definitely let me know when
you're done with with trying it out with
you I would I would love to see the
comparison I haven't worked with you yet
but I've read about it and definitely
interested in it so I'd be really
interested to compare compare the code
for those worlds asked when did you
learn to code or how long ago I would
say I've been doing I've been getting
back into front-end development for
about five years only the last three of
those five years what I'd say I've been
like seriously working on JavaScript
development before that it was more HTML
CSS a little bit of jQuery here and
there when I needed it so but I started
learning how to build websites when I
was in high school so probably around
2003 maybe around there I still did a
little bit with it later on in college
so maybe like 2005 I worked on it took a
class in C++ so I did a little bit with
it here and there
but I didn't really keep up with it too
much
but then I did some freelance stuff for
a few years and then about two years ago
I started working as a full-time
front-end developer here at Franciscan
University so that's about it I do have
a video on my youtube channel
I think it's linked in the description I
have a video where I talk more about my
journey to becoming a front-end
developer so if you're interested check
that out and you get some more some more
info about that cool Sebastian says
we're here to back you up awesome I
really appreciate that you all actually
have helped so much with making these
projects awesome but also making me a
much better coder by going through all
your pull requests and
you know getting all this advice that
you give me in the live chat I just I've
learned more in the last few months that
I've been live streaming then probably
in the last year before that so it's
definitely awesome that's actually what
I'm going to give a talk at the November
conference at the end of November in
Nashville Tennessee and my whole talk is
going to be about how live streaming has
been such an amazing experience for me
and has helped me so much as a developer
and so yeah it's it's really been
awesome I appreciate you all okay
Michele says I like WordPress PHP is my
first language
awesome awesome that's that's good maybe
you can help out when if we have to edit
some things in WordPress it's good to
have a PHP person watching okay miss
nero says oktoberfest may have something
to do with all this pull request huh
yeah I thought that I there's a lot of
people trying to get that free t-shirt
and get this pull requests in so it's
nice to use that label all right so my
five minutes is up I'm going to come
back and finish up the questions but I
do want to go through the rest of these
pull requests at least just a nice
outline of them so let's I tell you what
I'm going to set this timer but I don't
think we're going to need all this time
so I expect to finish up before the
twenty five minutes and let me know what
you think about this kind of stream
right we're not doing very much coding
but we are kind of going over a lot that
I think we need to go over for everyone
try having to everyone being able to be
on the same page with where this project
at since it's changed so much
since Friday so let me know if you're
not interested in this we'll try to
figure out some other way to keep
everybody in the loop in terms of the
changes and I'll just stick to trying to
do coding but otherwise I think I would
only do this if there's a lot of changes
like we have today I'm I don't think I
would do this frequently but there's a
lot to change its kind of needed all
right so the next the next thing that
we're going to do actually I do want to
say this if anybody has worked with
different types of authentication
especially with node let me know I'm
very interested in you know what your
thoughts are or if there's anything I
should look into more like I said I
still am not sure how things are going
to work out with my IT department and
trying to integrate everything with what
they're doing that's the best-case
scenario but I I'm definitely open to
trying to figure out something else with
authentication if we need to so anyway
we do have some unit testing now so this
is I actually I am going to show you a
bit about what was done here so we have
let me I always just want to show you
some of the tests so I mean you can
check out all the packages that were
installed here but let me show you the
tests I get stung further down whereas
there we go here's some of the tests so
a lot of these tests right now are just
saying you know hey did it render did it
actually render which is fine that's
that's a good test
so these run when you commit your code
so you're not you won't be able to
commit unless the code passes these
tests which is awesome so basically you
can see it's pretty straightforward even
if you don't know anything about testing
in this particular way it's not hard to
see what's going on so we see at bar
renders without crashing right that's
that's it that's that's the test so so
we just want to see if things render
some of them we got a little bit more so
we're actually seeing like does it
render a category right I think we're
doing another one where it's rendering
something else but basically you can see
the test could be a little bit more
in-depth and maybe we'll get to that
once we build things out a little bit
more but for now at the very least it
checks to make sure any changes hasn't
caused part of the app to to not render
so anyway so really useful so if you
want to write some tests feel free
especially if anybody's more experienced
at writing tests as you all may know
I've mentioned before I'm still pretty
inexperienced with testing so I'm gonna
be trying to understand testing and
write some more tests I did some with
our previous project that we had some
testing on but that's what that's what
we mean by by testing at least for right
now this isn't the only way to do
testing we certainly could add you know
some different types of tests but this
will we have for now
and it's awesome that we just have you
know some testing in there we also have
this announcement form so
show you so now we have a way to submit
announcements so users can submit now
this is not tied in at all to the
backend so we still need this data to be
sent to our server and then from the
server to be sent by email to someone
here in my department and then also an
email back to actually we don't have a
spot for email hmm oh you know what
we're currently getting the users email
so we already have the email of someone
who's logged in so we are sending the
email back to the user we don't have to
get the email here in the forum because
we already have it so assuming that we
can still get the email address of the
user which we should be able to do
because I think the login will still be
based on email and not necessarily
username so we'll grab the email we send
two emails one to the person who
submitted it and one to someone here in
my department and they can also upload
files so we're gonna need I actually had
another modal that popped up when you
click this with some further
instructions so we'll see if we want to
do that the same way or figure out a
better way to do that but that's that's
in place now which is great and we had
so let's see key there may sir if I'm
mispronouncing the name I don't know if
gear may is here or not in the live chat
but the air Mesa has added some
information to the readme basically the
readme file was referencing some stuff
from an old project so it wasn't this
current project so it was and then added
some things about using yarn so that was
good hopefully no one got too confused
if they had read the readme recently and
then also added some info about that
node
version that I was telling you about
earlier that we need at least version
7.6
to be able to run the server so those
are all the requests so quite a few
requests a lot of code and let me share
with you the contributors now so I
haven't done this for a while but here's
everyone that's contributed so far so
awesome work to everyone that's
contributed I really appreciate it and
you can see based on commits I'm no
longer the top contributor so I need to
I need to get moving but anyway I really
appreciate everything so if anyone has
any questions about any of those commits
about what was done or how it was done
let me know I can certainly go back over
them in more depth
I'd like for us all to be able to
understand you know what's going on so I
mean I definitely took a lot more time
to go through it on my own so I it may
not be as clear in the brief overview
that I've given but you'll see I'm going
to be adding to these issues into our
project so if you're interested in
contributing but you're not sure what to
do keep an eye on that on the issues and
give it a shot
I if you submit an issue and you didn't
do it quite right I can always just give
you some feedback and you can improve it
so don't worry about submitting
something wrong I'm the worst that could
happen is I just say hey you need to
change this or oh you know somebody
already submitted something that fix
that so no big deal don't be afraid to
submit if you want to see and also if
you notice something that's not working
correctly with the app open up an issue
I I certainly am NOT going to be able to
catch everything it's always awesome to
have you know other people fresh eyes
looking at the project and you know I'm
sure all of you use different operating
systems devices browsers and you'll
catch some things that that I just won't
so all right I'm gonna go back to the
live chat I'm gonna answer some more
questions and it's okay yeah we're about
right on track to have that our our time
for this stream so tomorrow we'll
definitely be doing some some coding so
this stream is kind of just to catch up
stream not really the norm okay let's go
back let's see do you dilip I'm not sure
I can't I says hey W DLC for the start
I'm not sure what W DLC is somebody let
me know what that means and then I'll
answer the question
okay Ronald says have you looked at Zen
hub for github I actually I think that
is what I looked at so I mentioned that
I did see something that worked with
github I think it was in hub so Ronald
if you I know you you mentioned that a
while ago so if you're still there let
me know do you use Zen hub for github
and if so how do you like it
hey John Hansen's here he says hi all
hey John thanks for joining us Oh Eric
says bitbucket can use Trello boards now
which is pretty cool that is cool I
didn't realize that
Blake says hey Jesse I'm watching the
videos over and over watching the videos
over again and copying the code over as
there are a lot of PRS in there in the
repo yeah definitely a lot of hearts
Umberto's says yet yeah Alberto's my
dotnet guy on the stream definitely very
helpful whenever we were working on some
dotnet stuff a few weeks back satya says
yeah it's helping me awesome glad I
could help
thanks for watching Meriter says this
first week is tough gonna have to watch
your video later ciao for now okay see
you later Umberto I'm sure you're gone
already but thanks for watching
Blake says if I'm building this myself
do you think i need PRS 12 through 13
and 15 through 22 let me check with
those PRS were again 12
yet not necessarily so if you don't need
some of those features that we're being
added then I don't think that you need
them so for sure you can get kind of the
basics down up to maybe around PR right
right around PR 12 I guess would be a
decent place I mean the air handling.i
is is kind of nice but yeah anything
beyond that in terms of the the server
you may or may not want that a
client-side API call would probably just
fine if you had no need of
authentication
Sacha's has hi Jesse from India hey
Satya
glad you could join us from India it's
pretty late there right it's definitely
try think what time it would be in India
was it like - somewhere around 2:30 in
the morning something like that I can't
remember the exact time but thanks for
staying up so late
rook says hi everyone join late hey ro
glad you could join Pat says is there a
formal QA / testing process that you go
through before you go live with work how
formal a process does your school have
the process is actually not it's not
really formalized so I definitely think
we need something more formalized but
for now the testing process is depending
on what the project is and and how
necessary it is it will go through more
rigorous testing than than other
projects but there's no basically if I
say it's ready to go then it goes so
everybody trusts that all of you
thorough testing so it's
thing is pretty much all on me and I
just do as much as I can and usually we
have four projects in the past done had
groups of people here at the University
to get early access to things and let
them test and give me feedback so we
have done use some of the automated
testing in previous projects and some
like we're doing now and then otherwise
just try to do as much user testing as
we can honestly there have been some
times when we we had a date things had
to go live and I would have rather done
more testing but it worked for most of
the use cases that we had and and it
launched and then later on we just tried
to to improve things as much as we could
I'm usually thinking more like browsers
like older browsers making sure it works
then those are the things that usually
kind of get pushed the side you know we
try to test with the main the browsers
that we know people are most likely to
use and and then just wait you know that
when we have more time for the other
ones so I definitely have to read up
more on testing process I'd like to have
I'd love to have more automated testing
that happens and and then perhaps some
sort of formal process you know right
now
right now with it just being me mostly
who makes that decision I I just have
been putting off doing something like
that but if we end up having more people
working on things it's going to be
necessary to have some sort of
established process so if anybody has
experience with that I'm definitely open
to hearing your thoughts on it
and I do run I use I forget what it's
called but there's some sort of service
that checks your github repositories to
see if any of the JavaScript libraries
are using have security issues so I do
some testing like that as well okay all
right rook says passport J s is a is
great for authentication and node use it
recently to implement a login with
Facebook
o auth to button it makes it really
straightforward okay cool I'll I'll
check that out I think I've heard about
that before I think someone else
mentioned a livestream to I know I
looked at it before I actually I think I
looked at it when I was originally
building this bulletin last year and at
the time I I was not gonna run a note
back and I just didn't know enough about
it at the time so I just kind of passed
the passed it by but at this point I
think I and we definitely have the
skills to implement that so I'm gonna
check into that thank you for the
suggestion
oh cool Blake says I like the break
gives me some time to catch up on other
videos okay cool
Ronald says just to notice it's a
commercial project just nope just ran
across it okay cool thanks for for them
you know about it and that was in
response to what was it called I forgot
already the github Zen hub Zen hub
forget up alright Pat says web
development lifecycle
okay cool check
okay cool I'm checking that out on my
other screen the web development
lifecycle cool yeah I definitely need I
need a better process oh okay cool
thanks uncle Pat so that was the W DLC
comment from earlier okay let me go back
and look at that comment now that I
understand what it is okay so a W DLC
for the start okay
so obviously no I didn't I didn't use W
DLC but now that I'm looking at it here
on my other screen this is awesome I
need to I need to look more into this so
I mean obviously let me just pull this
on this screen just to give you an
overview in case I'm sure a lot of you
are familiar with this already but it's
assuming that this is an accurate
representation it seems like these are
just the steps for web development to
gather information planning do with
wireframe mock-up design content then
coding testing review launch and then
maintenance so these are things that
usually happen but they don't these
usually happen for my projects but not
necessarily as distinct steps like this
or mapped out and sometimes they're in a
different order I think it wouldn't
definitely be helpful to put this in a
better order because I'm sure if you
watch before a previous things sometimes
we get out of order with this and we get
stuck a bit in a loop where we're
content isn't even decided on we're
almost all the way finished with coding
and the content in the design aren't
even completely decided on yet some of
this is out of my hands I don't write
the content so sometimes we just get
started and have to wait on the content
otherwise we'd be waiting for a long
time and never get it coded
I do like this idea we should we should
definitely follow this for the upcoming
project because that's going to be a
huge project in it it will require some
some organization more so than we have
been for these small projects we've been
able to get away with it because the
projects are such small scale but I
think we definitely need something more
formal ok it's 1 a.m. in India
all right oh that's right I remember now
so - 2 p.m. or I'm sorry 4 p.m. here in
the United States Eastern time is 2:00
a.m. in India all right I knew there was
it was around that time
okay Risha bass will there be a caste
related to Jess so will I do a stream
let's see I maybe I will
I need to learn more about about just so
it's a possibility I don't feel
comfortable doing a stream on it right
now because I know so so little about it
so I think it would be great to do a
stream on that and it's something that I
should know more about anyway so I'm
going to keep that in mind and try to do
a stream on its in nears it says I just
made my first pool request awesome
congratulations did you do a pull
request for this for this project and
see where was it at I get up open let's
see if it's for this one
I don't see him for this one maybe it's
for a different one but anyway
congratulations on your first pull
request let's see John B says Jessie on
the topic of service that checks for
JavaScript libraries that may have
security vulnerabilities was the service
you were thinking of called sync IO yeah
I think it's sync is anybody else use
sync dot IO I have it linked up to my
github account and so it just checks all
my repositories usually I get warnings
sometimes about different versions of
jQuery surprisingly a lot of different
versions of jQuery show up as having
some sort of security issue
so I'm not sure I mean sites that that
need to use jQuery I'm not sure what to
do about it cuz sometimes you need to
use certain versions to work with other
things that you're using but yeah it's
pretty useful it doesn't cover
everything so it's not I wouldn't trust
it a hundred percent but it's nice to
have to have the warning there and I
think I I'm pretty sure it comes up in
my console I have some sort of plugin
see if I I don't know if I have a site
open that would give me an error right
now but I also get a warning message in
my console which is nice okay let's see
all right well I've gotten to the bottom
of the live chat and we're coming in at
just over an hour so for once my
estimate of how long something would
take actually works
I normally underestimate every time we
do a stream so let's see okay John B
just said I remember because the guy who
made synced at a conference talk on
JavaScript phone abilities that criminal
hackers like to exploit okay cool
that actually sounds really interesting
talk on that I just I don't usually hear
that much about JavaScript boner
abilities so I would definitely
interested in that okay cool
so a little bit of a different stream
today kind of it was kind of different
it was kind of weird for me sitting I
didn't write any code but I think
hopefully we're all on the same page now
we know we have some project planning in
place and I'll be adding to that you
feel free to add to that as well and we
got a new project coming up that's going
to be huge and exciting I've been I've
been wanting to redo the main website
here at the University since before I
even got the job here so this is I'm
really really excited and I'm glad now
like everybody in my department the head
of my department is on board and I think
there there are people even higher up
that are going to be on board with it so
I think this is really gonna happen so
I'm excited and I'll keep you up-to-date
on anything you know before we start
I'll keep you up-to-date on anything
that happens that may delay it or
different decisions about what it's
going to look you know what exactly
we're going to do but it'll be awesome
it'll be it'll be a huge project and
it'll be really cool and maybe I'm kind
of thinking that maybe we could sneak
somewhere in the site maybe in a console
all the list of everybody that submitted
pull requests just to thank you so we'll
see I think that would be fun and then
anybody that inspects uses the the dev
tools will see everybody that
contributed but all right cool so I
guess that that's it for me today should
be back tomorrow probably around 2:00
p.m. and until then thanks for watching
and have a great day